in many respects the program was
uncharted territory for the CIA and we
were not prepared we had little
experience housing detainees and
precious few of our officers were
trained interrogators but the president
authorized the effort six days after 911
and it was our job to carry it out when
the president came into office in
January 2009 he took the position that
these techniques were contrary to our
values and he unequivocally banned their
use he has consistently expressed the
view that these techniques did
significant damage to America's standing
in the world and made it harder to
pursue our interests with allies and
partners the previous administration
faced agonizing choices about how to
pursue al Qaeda and prevent additional
terrorist attacks against our country
while facing fears of further attacks
and carrying out the responsibility to
prevent more catastrophic loss of life
there were no easy answers there was
information obtained subsequent to the
application of vit s from detainees that
was useful in the bin Laden operation